digamos que tenemos una pelota que
dejamos caer de una altura de 10 metros
muy bien dejamos caer la pelota de una
altura de 10 metros y cada vez que
rebota sube la mitad de altura que que
tenía en el rebote anterior por ejemplo
si tenemos aquí la pelota que la dejamos
caer a 10 metros entonces después la
pelota va a rebotar hacia arriba la
mitad del rebote anterior que en este
caso serían 5 metros entonces aquí
estamos
5 metros
uff qué feo 55 metros muy bien y la
siguiente vez que rebote pues será a la
mitad de esta altura que sean a 2.5
metros ahí tienen ustedes la pelota y va
a estar a una altura de 2.5 metros muy
bien y entonces lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es ver cuál es la distancia
total que recorre la pelota por supuesto
la distancia vertical entonces vamos a
ver en el primer en el primer rebote
pues baja 10 metros verdad entonces
tendremos 10 metros y luego en el
siguiente rebote va a subir 5 y luego
baja 5 entonces tendremos
digamos la mitad de 10 que es 10 por un
medio más la mitad de 10 que es 10 por
un medio verdad es esta primera es
cuando sube y esta segunda es cuando
baja aquí realmente no tenemos que
considerar en las direcciones
simplemente tenemos que ver cuánta es la
distancia total que recorre entonces por
ejemplo aquí fueron 10 luego sube 5 y
baja 5 entonces ahí sumamos 10 5 y 5 de
hecho aquí en este segundo paso pues
hace un total de 10 metros verdad vamos
a ver qué pasa en el siguiente en el
siguiente sube 2.5 y baja 2.5 entonces
2.5 estamos pensando que es la mitad de
la mitad de 10 entonces son 10 por un
medio al cuadrado más 10 por un medio al
cuadrado y así esta pelota seguirá
rebotando una infinidad de veces pero
cada vez con una menor altura ok
entonces estos tienen una
era muy parecida a una serie geométrica
vamos a tratar de expresar lo de la
siguiente forma entonces lo que tenemos
aquí son 10
dos veces diez a la un medio dos veces
diez a la un medio en realidad son 20
veces al 20 por un medio verdad entonces
tenemos 20 por un medio y aquí otra vez
tenemos 10 por un medio al cuadrado dos
veces entonces estos serán 20 por un
medio al cuadrado y entonces esto ya
casi tiene cara de una serie geométrica
excepto que nos gustaría que el primer
término fuera 20 bueno por eso es muy
fácil porque entonces podremos sumar b
sumar 10 para que nos dé 20 y
restárselos entonces restamos 10 y
sumamos 20 nos da más 20 y luego queda
exactamente lo mismo verdad más 20 por
un medio
20 por un medio al cuadrado y así
seguimos sumando verdad entonces el
primer término el este este 20 lo
podemos ver como 20 por un medio a la 0
y aquí ya tenemos exactamente bueno aquí
e igual elevado a la 1 tenemos una serie
geométrica donde nada más le restamos 10
entonces lo que vamos a tener es los
siguientes menos 10 pero ponerlo con
verde mejor
y ahora un poquito de más entonces
tendremos menos 10
esta serie geométrica la suma desde acá
igual a cero hasta infinito de 20 por un
medio al acá muy bien y ya sabemos cómo
calcular esta serie geométrica verdad ya
sabemos que cualquier serie geométrica
donde la proporción común tiene valor
absoluto menor que 1 digamos si es la
serie a por el real acá donde acá
empieza en cero y termina en infinito
será igual a entre 1 - r otra vez r debe
tener un valor absoluto menor que 1 ok
entonces en nuestro caso cuanto vale
todo esto esto de aquí pues será 20 que
es nuestra 20 entre 1 - r que es uno
menos uno
entonces esto es 20 entre 1 menos un
medio es un medio y 20 entre un medio es
lo mismo que 2 por 20 y estos son 40 sin
embargo no hemos terminado porque hay
que restarle 10 así que esto será menos
10 más 40 son 30 metros entonces cuánto
fue lo que recorrió de distancia total
esta pelota que va rebotando una y otra
vez pero cada vez menos pues en realidad
son sólo 30 metros